[Música]
una quinta de bienvenidos no es más a
esta edición de canadá en las américas
café
el programa de espacio del reencuentro
de la sección en español de radio canadá
internacional que ofrecemos cada viernes
esperando
[Música]
como ustedes saben esta emisión está
disponible no solamente a través de
youtube live que es cada vez más
consumido por nuestro auditorio sino
también a través de facebook live y por
supuesto a otras de nuestro sitio en
internet nuestra página web www r/c y
net punto sea sí por si alguien lo sabe
[Risas]
pero como no la noté una vez por todas
bueno estamos aquí presentes en estudio
pablo gómez barrios y en labor de
muchísimas gracias hola a todos
paloma martínez que está luis qué tal a
todos
leonardo jiménez etarios esta vez sin
ningún tipo de disfraz no no no me estoy
dejando la barba porque pone empezó a
empezar las temperaturas bajo cero
continuas así que me tengo que hablar la
piel de oso tiene que empezar a salir y
quiera porque era muy joven no no no lo
mío es no es movember es bar bemberg
localidades para protegerme del frío y
esa barra promisorio de las 10 a las 10
es lo que pasa es que no me protege
todavía pero empiezo con el proceso
ojalá pudiera ser así como que fuera
grande como nuestro querido colaborador
de aquel lado pero lamentablemente que
deja pasar tiempo así que supongo que
entre un par de semanas parecerá una
barba por ahora parece sucio porque
nuestra ilusión y una postiza no probase
he probado he probado funciona pero no
consigo de mi tono tan especial de
cabello así que
así que va a ser son los recursos que
apela cierta gente para pasar el
invierno de la mejor manera posible que
es un invierno largo va a estar vamos a
ver ese tema aquí y en la punta de la
mesa tenemos una invitada como ya es
habitual tenemos cada semana intentamos
al menos tener alguien invitado en este
caso se trata del natalicio que es
cantante no sé si te gusta deficiente
como cantante lírica o no cantante
lírica cómica un clown no lo que quieres
porque ha probado ya otros estilos no
solamente la lírica propiamente dicha no
no me gustan todos los estilos es de
hecho el último disco hay más de un
estilo presente también si vamos a
hablar de ello en pocos instantes más
pero antes que nada queremos arrancar el
tema haciendo referencia a una de las
cuestiones que ha traído la tensión
durante esta última semana en el plano
político internacional y es
indudablemente la situación que se ha
planteado en bolivia donde ha habido un
cambio de gobierno de la peor manera
posible en todo caso porque no ha sido a
través de elecciones
formales propiamente dichas sino a
través de lo que se conoce lo que se ha
conocido históricamente no sólo en
américa latina en otras partes del mundo
como un golpe de estado aunque hay mucha
gente que se resiste a llamarlo de esta
manera pero ha habido en todo caso la
dimisión de un presidente evo morales
que ha debido abandonar su puesto por
una entre comillas sugerencia primero de
la policía mod y nada y después de las
fuerzas armadas cuando esta sugerencia
existe de parte de un cuerpo armado poco
se puede hablar de su mujer es el que
tiene el arma es el que tiene la voz más
pesada bueno
en la última semana porque esto el
desplazamiento de evo morales- ocurrió
el domingo último en la última semana
han ocurrido innumerable cantidad de
sucesos en bolivia entre ellos por
supuesto protestas
represión la toma del poder por parte de
un gobierno con una presidenta que se ha
autoproclamado que era senadora hasta
antes de asumir la presidencia de
bolivia evo morales que está exiliado en
el exterior en mexico que fue el país
que lo acogió pocas horas después de que
se produjo el golpe y que está hablando
de que está dispuesto a retornar a
bolivia para apaciguar para pacificar en
todo caso al país y la situación aparece
minuto a minuto en lugar de ir mejorando
en lugar de ir solucionando se parece
cada vez más compleja es bastante
complejo lo que sucedió en bolivia
porque hay que recordar que jeanine áñez
que es quien se autoproclamó como
presidenta de bolivia era una senadora
boliviana que reclamó la presidencia
primero del senado cuando adriana
salvatierra que es que era presidente
del senado en ese momento y por encima
en rango de áñez en términos de la
constitución boliviana ella boicoteó
adriana salvatierra boicoteó la sesión
parlamentaria
tenía que tomar la decisión con respecto
a lo que iba a suceder en bolivia
después de la renuncia de evo morales y
en el momento en que ella boicoteó esto
pues entonces áñez entro a proclamarse
también presidenta del senado boliviano
y a partir de eso pues siendo presidenta
y la única representante oficial en ese
momento se convertiría en ese mismo
momento en presidenta de bolivia porque
el vicepresidente estaba fuera del país
y el presidente también el que acaba de
renunciar como presidente también
entonces había como un vacío de poder y
ahí es donde jeanine áñez se declaró
digamos que hubo un pronunciamiento de
la policia amotinada que en primera
instancia le pidió la renuncia a evo
morales a esto se sumó luego un grupo de
extracción evangélica que se hizo
presente en la casa del gobierno en
bolivia e introdujo reintrodujo dicen
ellos la biblia y bien en la casa de
gobierno luego se pronunció horas más
tarde el ejército que también se sumó al
pedido de renuncia
morales y luego apareció esta senadora
que no era la inmediatamente la que
seguía inmediatamente en la línea de
sucesión sino que como decías paloma
había por lo menos dos o tres personas
antes que ella pero ante el vacío y la
confusión que se produjo porque de hecho
varias horas durante el domingo y el
lunes el país estuvo sin gobierno
nadie crisis y está a cargo del gobierno
formalmente más tarde consiguió el apoyo
del ejército y se autoproclamó entonces
presidenta de la nación y está tomando
ya algunas medidas con los integrantes
de su nuevo gabinete que entre otras
cosas han prometido represión a los
policías que marc informes y represión
persecución nos vamos a casar dijeron
esto realmente es detener la situación
es muy muy delicada y es un retroceso de
bolivia como país
hablamos recién con pablo a una más de
las cuantas ciento 180
y un retroceso también para la región
siendo que es si hubieron
irregularidades o no ya es cosas de muy
muy pasado porque realmente lo que está
pasando ahora es de una violencia
inusitada y bueno introdujeron la biblia
sólo falta el calefón igual que el tango
sin lengua y cambalache
pero no sólo entró la biblia sino que
sacaron también la bandera del
tahuantinsuyo que estaba lo primero que
hicieron de hecho fue sacar la bandera
que es la bandera que representa de
alguna forma a los pueblos indígenas de
el altiplano y entonces pues fue
representar ya de indígenas en bolivia
alrededor de 61 por ciento se sacaron de
cuajo el 61 por ciento del país o sea no
el país evidentemente está dividido se
veían hacer protestas por televisión con
gente que repudiaba el golpe con gente
que decía que no había habido un golpe y
que apoyaba a las nuevas autoridades
evidentemente en bolivia hay por lo
menos como mínimo 2
1 el país indígena y otro compuesto por
todos los demás los que no son indígenas
como decía en todo caso leonardo es una
vuelta atrás un paso atrás en la región
y a raíz de las irregularidades que vos
mismo señalaban hay que recordar también
el triste papel que ha jugado la
organización organización perdón de
estados americanos la oea que en buena
medida ha sido uno de los actores
principales en toda la confusión que se
armó a comienzos de semana porque
hablaron o dieron a conocer un documento
que hablaba de irregularidades luego
dijeron que estas irregularidades no
empañaban el resultado de las elecciones
que se llevaron a cabo en el mes de
octubre más tarde dijeron que sí que
eran más graves lo que se dijo en un
primer momento y yo creo que en el día
de hoy ni siquiera los analistas
políticos que se especializan en la
cuestión boliviana son capaces de
decirnos qué es lo que dijo la oea y
creo que yo creo que tenemos un vídeo de
un periodista argentino
trabaja en el canal telefé de buenos
aires que está en su habitación de hotel
no tenemos el audio en este momento pero
él habla de que estaba a punto de ser
evacuado porque la situación de la
violencia se ha expandido
ahí está entonces diciendo exactamente
esto que yo estoy refiriendo y deja en
claro que la violencia no solamente
tiene que ver ahora entre distintos
sectores que componen la vida política
propia de bolivia sino que también se la
ha emprendido con los periodistas y en
muchos casos las autoridades de los
distintos medios de comunicación han
preferido movilizar los a otras
ficciones o incluso sacarlos del país
ante la posibilidad que puedan ser
atacados violentamente y poner en riesgo
entonces la vida de estas personas se
veía a ser también la imagen de un
periodista de la cadena rusa rt
guaita no me valora su nombre de pila se
me escapa el nombre francisco guaita con
quien trabaje a quien conozco
personalmente que estaba haciendo
apremiado en algún momento por la gente
que no estaba de acuerdo con lo que
estaba diciendo en su crónica desde la
ciudad de la paz así que la situación en
este momento no es buena ni para la
población ni para las autoridades
supongo yo tampoco ni para los que se
fueron del poder ni para los periodistas
ni para nadie ni para lo que están ni
para la región que es peor ni es para
ganar democracia gana más efectivamente
bueno entonces nuestra referencia a uno
de los casos que reflejó uno de los
temas principales esta semana y vos
tenés algún mensaje
leonardo sigue aquí es bueno saludos de
ismael zamora y de gustavo lucas que es
tan bueno chequeando esta transmisión y
miran alarcón dice hola desde argentina
200 que américa latina hay un retroceso
una vuelta a un tiempo que pensé que no
volvería ese es el mensaje de nuestros
oyentes e encuesta bolu caixa saludos de
la ciudad me lo departamento de cerro
largo uruguay y saludos desde ser la
tierra
el zamora son las personas que nos
escriben en nuestras redes sociales
aprovecho también entonces para
agradecer a homero matizaba el que nos
había hecho llegar vídeos referidos a la
cuestión de bolivia también no los hemos
podido programar para esta ocasión pero
le agradecemos su colaboración y en todo
caso el tema seguramente va a extenderse
veremos en una próxima emisión de
utilizar el material que él nos ha hecho
de llegar tan gentilmente
si ustedes están de acuerdo cerramos en
bolivia
bueno yo voy a hablar del tema de
bolivia al final programa de la semana
activamente pero ahora vamos a entonces
darle espacio a nuestra invitada del día
de hoy que es natal hizo que sí mucho
gusto
estoy muy bien gracias que habla
perfectamente español a pesar de que
hace un rato me decía que no
perfectamente no casi perfecto no porque
cuando era pequeña
viví en lima perú para tres años
entonces aprendí en la escuela y el
castellano y el peruano
y ahora después viví en italia y ahí
aprendí el italiano entonces perdón si a
veces
algunas palabras italianas y las lenguas
más de una dos o tres lenguas es fácil
confundir las cuando se parecen si como
italiano y también español y también
portugués
sí pero estudie también en latino y eso
ayuda a comprender todas las idiomas
latinas entonces me ayudan mucho bueno
natalie es cantante lírica básicamente
aunque no sea tal estilo lírico
solamente pero es conocida su
trayectoria en ese rubro y estás
presentando en pocos días más un nuevo
disco que se llama en español se llama
colores sí que incluye diversos estilos
musicales puedes contarnos al respecto
sí claro
este disco nací con una idea de mi gente
aquí en quebec y dice por qué no haces
un disco que habla de pinturas pinturas
y obras de arte y todo y
yo hablé con mi hija florence que está
aquí a quien gusta mucho la música
latina
y ella me dice mamá qué idea formidable
hicimos un disco quiero hacer tu
productor
y también lo mío productor de disco
larbi mancini que el extinta ya no dice
sí sí yo también quiero bueno y flamas
dice yo tengo mi amigo osvaldo montes
que es argentino y que escriben música
para fin televisión y que es para el
tipo de voz que tengo es una buena idea
porque mi lado lírico como necesita
música música un poco tipo morricone o
cinematográfica
entonces la aventura empecé así y yo
pensé que ópera o para darte que obrar
me gusta entonces lo están
son tantas las obras que me gustan pero
hay una canción que si la canción que se
llama colores para quinquela martín sus
magníficas pinturas que habla de los
inmigrantes que fueron que construyeron
la ciudad de buenos aires también
guayasamín el pintor de ecuador con el
tema de los humanos
y también el pensamiento que hay detrás
detrás de de las obras en las manos que
supieron sufrir psuv sufrieron que
amaron que trabajaron que exprimen que
lograron y todas estas cosas son se ven
en la expresión artística y también
porque yo nací en tokio o hokusai
muy lindo pintor de japón es entonces
una canción que se llama fujiyama y pero
mi hija la que ama la hiena llama fuji
mamá y otra vez cante también un
avemaría para miquel àngel
hoy hay muchas a frida kahlo también una
ranchera entonces para eso hay muchas
canciones en español y para eso el disco
se llama colores también para todo el
que ve aquí y de aquí es muy sentimental
me gustaría soy sentimental
me gusta la música latina porque los a
chinos son sentimentales como como gente
muy emotivos también
a mí me gusta la ópera porque es
sentimental es motivo de emoción es
emoción al respecto quería preguntarte
precisamente cuando uno piensa en un
cantante o una cantante hídricos' piensa
en alguien que tiene una formación muy
clásica en materia musical y además
mucha disciplina mucha práctica mucho
estudio cómo se da el giro hacia géneros
que no están necesariamente emparentados
con la música lírica como sea el giro
hacia el tango hacia la ranchera y sobre
todo hacia el humor porque creo que es
desconocida mundialmente le contaba
recién que yo la conocí hace 20 años en
argentina es darnos disipó de un
programa en argentina donde había un
montón de invitados y hace parte del
show que presentaba en buenos aires y
era un show cómico
mezclando
y mezclándolo con una perfección
exquisita el humor con lo lírico y hay
gente que logró gracias a esa fusión
amar la lírica cómo se hace para mezclar
ese el humor y el canto pero de esa
manera más prosperar también sirve
pienso que lo que pasa es que yo
descubrí a la ópera cuando tenía 11 años
yo no quería ir a ver la ópera aída pero
mi papá dice mi hermana y yo tienes que
ir conmigo no he aburrido ópera pero
cuando fue a escucharlo con la sinfónica
en el éter medicara cala fue un como un
shock y hoy escuché esto estas voces y
es como hace un cuerpo humano hacer un
sonido tan tan grande y que me da la
piel de gallina entonces este día yo
nada este día y yo quería saber cómo
cantar como ellos y fue como una sesión
no quería hacer una carrera carrera
carrera operática quería solamente saber
cantar como ellos pero paralelamente y
también los novios de mi hermana que era
rubia con ojos verdes era muy popular
todos venían en casa con guitarra y
cantaban beatles y nana mouskouri
cat stevens y yo aprendí la guitarra y
me gustaba también mucho el folclore las
canciones simples muy lindas pero
tan emoción y entonces aprendí cada vez
que venir como se hace la mayor y
entonces para eso creo que nunca perdí
la posibilidad de ir de un estira a un
otro y después quería ser músico
terapeuta para ayudar a gente que a
veces las palabras no pueden exprimir
las cosas que la alma lloran entonces
pero el padre de florence lo encontré y
me dicen no con esta voz tienes que
cantar entonces así como empiece mí me
la carrera de cantante y mezcle la el
humor con la ópera para hacer mucha
felicidad en el público porque me digo
pan durante 23 horas están felices y se
olvidan los problemas y la belleza de la
música que viene en tu alma cuando
después
te llena y te abre puertas cerradas que
con la vida se cierran puertas de
felicidades pero se pueden abrir alabas
un rato de que naciste en japón
que viviste en perú si hablabas también
de ciro nos decías también nos contaba
de qué hablas varias lenguas
a qué se debe esto a que se ve tú tu
paso por distintos lugares del mundo y
hable a distintas lenguas y bueno es el
trabajo de mi padre que trabajaba en la
embajada canadiense entonces nosotros
las hijas los seguimos seguimos y así
cambiamos de una escuela en un idioma a
una otra en inglés en francés en
italiano en
en español sí después también con el
canto lírico aprendes un poco de alemán
para las óperas de mozart para la
provincia y también nos ruso viví en
moscú también entonces anios de mix top
kate como dicen no sé de dónde vengo una
ensalada mixta pues se transcurrió en
buena parte en perú pues son los
recuerdos que tienes de perú
tenía una señora tan linda que se
llamaba así quina o siquiera que estaba
con nosotros cuando papá y mamá
trabajaban y su calor humano y una cosa
como cuando tenemos la tos dice una
medicina tradicional autóctono si es
cebolla miel y limón
cuando tienes datos que te vas a beber
esta cosa como la cebolla
con la cebolla como el psuv y jugo jugos
italia mamma mia west italiana y
entonces estoy también la música peruana
y mi mamá escuchaba también muchas
muchas muchas cosas el folclore y una
vez fuimos a ver un teatro musical y era
muy pequeña pero me acuerdo que el
personaje me parecía tan grande y como
mi hermana que a quien nos gusta ir en
el estuviera en el escenario era rubia
con ojos verdes siempre los artistas
cuando tienen que escoger uno se van a
buscar mi hermana que no quería ir
pero nunca
me acuerdo de una frase de una canción
no sé por qué arroz compacto me quiero
casar con una señorita de portugal
esta frase de la misa ya que es tan
linda
con el compositor y una cosa muy
interesante
él hacía muchas giras en el interior del
país y fue con todos con samba aquí
píldora con toda la troupe que lo seguía
para todos lados y una vez preparó la
obra la misa criolla y la navidad
nuestra con el coro de jubilados de la
ciudad san luis donde yo vivía
los jubilados no daban tanto como él
esperaba entonces le pidió ayuda lo
cantaba en el coro de la provincia y le
pidió dos o tres de cada cuerda y
nosotros fuimos y él nos reúne afuera y
nos dice son ustedes los que cantan
ellos
y él estaba con su granito y nos miraban
nos daban las señas a nosotros
[Risas]
qantas con tus tres hijas
mis tres hijas si tengo tres hijas y las
tres cantan
sin presión si no quieren quieren cantar
cuando cuando lo pregunto y también en
mi segunda hija también hace una carrera
musical ahora se va con el circo el vals
para ocho meses
mi corazón de mamas llora pero estoy muy
feliz para ella y entonces también esa
es el yoga el león es la que hace y la
pequeña área en la que se ve pequeñas de
19 años cantando estrés y también el
barítono en chino químico que canta
conmigo en dueto ahí como me gusta su
voz su padre también cantaba wikileaks o
el chino y fuiste tú responsable de la
inclinación artística de tus hijas
tuviste tuvo algo que ver
si también papá porque son hechos son
dos patas el primo es egipcia no libanés
es el padre de flojos que toca la
guitarra pop pop es muy rítmico
periodista y todo ahí hay una de sus
canciones en el disco una canción vieja
de 60 años que me gusta tan para él como
hippie de la época hippie no es para el
arte un poco psicodélica y todo
y después
si así no el padre de los otros es
contrabajista charles entonces en casa
siempre música música música para ellas
es natural yo tenía que estudiar porque
mis padres no son para nada musicales
pero ellas desde cuando son pequeñas si
no trabajar mucho y es muy natural
entonces fue un disco familiar muy
hacerlo fue muy simpático con osvaldo
también que dormía en casa mía con su
novia a mí me gustan las cosas
familiares
vamos a aclarar que el disco es fresco
fresco la versión digital va a estar
disponible a partir del 29 6 que ellos
eso me pregunta a miriam alarcón dice
hermoso lo que dice natalie es
multicultural y multicolor me encantaría
me encanta que le invitaran y dice puede
escucharlo en spotify así que suponemos
que a partir de la fecha de lanzamiento
de esta canción
el 29 gracias muchas gracias si el 29 de
noviembre la versión digital y el 5 de
diciembre
el disco propiamente dicho pero material
fecha más importante del año más
importante
y se acuerda porque es el cumpleaños de
la madre
pueden escribir cartas para la mamá y
para natalie un género que no hayas
intentado aún y que te gustaría intentar
muy género musical
si hacer como si esta música con una voz
clásica porque yo pienso que la
la energía de esta música es como la
energía del del operativo sabes cuando
se cantaron
es como burlar un poco si logra tiene
mucha fuerza
y bueno cuantas composiciones hay en el
disco 11 11 de las 11 composiciones del
disco tienes una preferida
que me cuentan que mata no se que
despierte algo más que las otras no sé
por qué
pero sobre todas bonitas porque no hay
todas que pueda
hay muchos coros también en el disco en
bollywood el esquí que escribí estos
coros magníficos que que son como la
star del disco
omnipresente y son muy muy profundos y
armen me gusta mucho no entonces no de
todas alcanzándose porque hay la violín
en la ranchera y también la trompeta
pero todas fui para cuando entonces esa
fusión entre entre lírica y heavy metal
[Música]
[Risas]
tiene prevista el corto plazo
presentaciones en vivo si tengo una
quién
el domingo pero no el sábado y domingo
me voy en europa quien tengo 20
conciertos con es una organización que
se llama night
y no es la primera vez que hago turno
con ellos una vuelta con ellos pero cada
vez cambian artistas y el principio es
tienes la orquesta sinfónica un coro de
80 personas un banda rock y también 5
artistas y siempre uno clásico entonces
para esto yo tengo que hacer esto si soy
yo y hay también tres wind and fire que
se llevan a cantar
no es tener la suerte de hacer esta esta
vuelta con esto pero también
james mitchell
westin muchos artistas muy lindos
entonces me alegro de estoy muy contenta
de ir a hacer esta tourné pero del disco
va a haber va a haber alguna gira con él
y si vamos a hacer una gira con el disco
el año próximo con coros entonces cuando
estaré en el autobús de entre ciudades
en europa
voy a pensar que como voy a hacer pero
tengo que decir una cosa es que para
comprender lo que vivirán los pintores
y yo fue y si hice el ejercicio de
reproducir las pinturas pero yo no hice
pintura desde que tenía 5 años en perú
entonces descubrí una cosa mamma mía una
pasión yo que soy un poco hiperactiva
como se ve al italiana pero mis hijas me
dijo mamá nunca te vimos así concentrada
no moverte y mamma mía descubrir el
placer de
de lo que los colores como las emociones
de los colores quinquela martín sus
colores vivos y los detalles detalles de
esta fiesta
y olvide de comer de beber miraba el
reloj a las 5 de la mañana es una es una
droga formidable
[Risas]
entonces es fueron copias de obras
célebres pero quiero ver si tengo yo
algo que decir como de personal con esta
cosa cuando tendré tiempo voy a meter y
suele cantar a capella
si quieres algo
un pasaje sobre mí o
[Risas]
[Música]
fin
estoy
[Música]
[Aplausos]
gracias con cierre entrevista
agradecemos tu visita aquí a nuestros
estudios esperamos que no sea la única
vez que tengamos por aquí
acá tengo mensaje más a gilberto
martínez saludos de nicaragua y anabel
ya benavides no sé si la conocen esposa
dice eres magnífica natalie como un
vídeo a leo que soy los a tu lado
así que mi esposa está celosa y
envidiosa muchísimas gracias por los
mensajes también gracias natal y
nuevamente te quedas unos minutos más
con nosotros y quería entonces pedirte
leonardo si lo tienes disponible nuestra
aplicación sí señor de la aplicación
para que puedan ver nuestras noticias
inclusive nuestro vídeo nuestro programa
directamente porque nos olvidamos al
principio decir la aplicación también se
ve en vivo esta extensión es que al
agregar a la lista de medios exacto
ustedes pueden ir a las dos tiendas más
importantes de aplicaciones sea apostó a
google play que creo que se llama ahora
por qué cambiar el nombre y ponen ahí
irse y en español y pueden bajar nuestra
aplicación a partir de la versión en
español también pueden ver las
informaciones en las lenguas oficiales
es decir el francés y el inglés los
invitamos a bajar nuestra aplicación
entonces desde
perfecto para que tengan una opción más
veces ya pocas hay una y otra más
todavía bueno vamos a hacer lo siguiente
les pido a cada uno de ustedes que lean
la medida de lo posible un corto mensaje
de nuestros oyentes porque hace ya dos o
tres emisiones que no estamos leyendo
los mensajes y es una pena que se
pierdan después de que nuestro público
se ha tomado la molestia y ha tenido la
gentileza de escribirnos quien quiere
comenzar yo tengo aquí
tengo un mensaje un comentario sobre el
tema el español y los adultos mayores en
canadá y esmeralda beltrán dice gracias
por el reportaje y gracias por los
comentarios
ivonne a andrea con mucho gusto nos
pondremos en contacto creo que responde
a alguien que también había hecho un
comentario anterior sobre este mismo
tema entonces era esmeralda beltrán
sobre el español los adultos mayores en
canadá los ancianos
anciano
hablando de soles de esclerosis una
familia latinoamericana bien integrada
en canadá a mensah amenazada de
expulsión
carolina batalla dice hay que hay que
luchar familia sigo sin entender por qué
tienen que pasar a menores por estas
situaciones tan dolorosas los padres
hacemos lo que es mejor para nuestros
niños y al mismo tiempo es el mejor
trabajo para el futuro sobre todo en un
país donde lo que necesitan es personas
que ayuden a progresar tiene que hacer
alguna ley alguna asociación o algún
abogado que ayude a esta familia dios
los bendiga y nos acompañe es que claro
carolina batalla es también miembro de
otra familia que está en amenazada de
ser expulsada de canadá por eso comenta
la situación de otra familia entraron
en este caso el tema de esclerosis
múltiple investigadores se encuentran
una nueva pista para frenarla y jorge
martín dice una luz de esperanza para
convertir
esta enfermedad fue diagnosticado en
2017 actualmente ya me cuesta mucho
trabajo caminar a una felicitación y mi
reconocimiento a los investigadores
manifestando que estoy dispuesto a
colaborar en el momento que se requiera
para experimentar con humanos así que
jorge martín que está lamentablemente
con esta enfermedad dice que puede
ayudar bueno perfecto muchas gracias y
antes de pasar a los temas de esta
semana quería agradecerle a algunos
amigos cubanos que siguen utilizando el
correo postal para lanzarnos llegar sus
cartas y ellos son rafael reyes plaza
o danny álvarez peña justina maria
saldívar saldívar y tania espinoza pérez
a todos ellos muchísimas gracias por las
cartas las tenemos aquí las hemos leído
y las vamos a guardar como hacemos
siempre yo tengo un pequeño mensaje aquí
de gustavo luca un nuestro top fun que
escucha nuestro programa el programa en
inglés el programa francés en chino y en
árabe no 69 entiende algo por los
escucha y con comenta y yo creo que sí y
gustavo dice quiero saludar
especialmente a natalie yo podría salud
especial de natalie y lo dice en
italiano también porque evidentemente es
políglota así que gustavo el saludo para
natalie que está con nosotros aquí en
bueno y nos quedan a escasos ocho
minutos para comentar nuestros temas de
la semana así que voten a su mensaje
pablo muy cortito es canadá está trazado
con respecto a europa en la donación de
órganos y álex y dice quiero ser donador
también entonces no simplemente le
quería decir a alexis que si quiere
donar tiene simplemente que escribir
hombre detrás de la tarjeta d
[Música]
con el seguro médico y afirmando la
tarjeta es un donante y efectivamente
somos nosotros y que falló más tu tema
de la semana si en realidad yo quiero
resaltar en la posición que canadá tiene
un lado la la posición necesitan te
digamos que canadá tiene con respecto a
jeanine áñez com para reconocerla como
presidenta interina de bolivia enviamos
un mensaje a la al ministerio de
relaciones exteriores de canadá quien
nos respondió en un correo electrónico
donde cada palabra estaba muy bien
medida que canadá estaba siguiendo muy
de cerca la situación en bolivia y que
apoyaba una solución institucional que
permitirá que una administración por
provisional se prepare para nuevas
elecciones y evite un vacío de poder y
bueno en su mensaje el portavoz de
asuntos internacionales de canadá john
babcock que dijo que según la
constitución boliviana en ausencia del
presidente y del vicepresidente primero
de la cámara el vicepresidente segundo
del senado sería el siguiente
para asumir el papel de presidente o lo
que es cierto es que en el mensaje
que nos mandó nunca mencionaron el
nombre de jeanine áñez ni como
presidenta ni como vicepresidenta del
senado y tampoco como presidenta
interina de bolivia cuando las palabras
se miden no se olviden para que no
signifique entonces bueno lo que sí es
que el nombre de jeanine áñez no está
mencionado en ninguna de las de los
reconocimientos al respecto bueno yo
largo si básicamente es que todo el
mundo estaba preocupado con cuestionan
tecnologías sobre el nuevo la nueva
moneda que quiere sacar facebook y todo
el mundo estado como alarmado porque
esto estaba pasando bueno en base a esta
cripto moneda de esta moneda especial
para internet que no va a haber papel de
moneda de ese tipo de moneda china
anunció que en dos meses saque su propia
moneda
así que usando muchas de las bases que
zuckerberg había dicho de lo que sería
libra la moneda de facebook y justamente
para proteger el país en cuanto a la
cuestión del lavado de dinero eso son lo
que eso es lo que dicen las autoridades
chinas que lo hacen para eso para cuidar
la posición de china por no respecto al
mundo para cuidar el lavado de dinero
del narcotráfico y para reforzar las
capacidades de china para trabajar con
el resto del mundo así que se viene en
poco tiempo materiales que no hay una
fecha precisa no nos dicen dos o tres
meses en realidad supuestamente ahora en
noviembre noviembre no pasó pero no pero
dijeron que aproximadamente el 15 de
noviembre
gran titular no y entonces lo que pasa
es que están esperando porque en
realidad bastante complejo y es va a ser
la primera moneda que esté apoyada de
moneda virtual que esté apoyada por un
banco pablo gómez barrio 60 segundos
para tu intervención va a ser menos que
eso lo hice
[Risas]
hice una entrevista con guillermo paraje
quien es experto en economía de la salud
e investigador y profesor de la
universidad adolfo ibáñez de santiago de
chile que hizo una investigación sobre
los cigarrillos con cápsulas de sabor y
en chile en particular unos cigarrillos
que son muy populares en este momento y
que están incitando sobre todo a los
jóvenes a fumar entonces los invito a
escuchar esta entrevista con cigarrillo
que la persona que fuma puede activar
alguna de las farc en el cigarrillo y
absorbe el sabor hay dos cápsulas en el
cigarrillo la persona tiene la
posibilidad de activar una o dos o las
dos al mismo tiempo y el humo de su
cigarrillo va a estar perfume
tabaco como una marca la marca del
vaquero está sumiendo así hace años con
el momento normal volumen que mucha
gente dice que los cigarrillos que
tienen sabores son además más peligrosos
porque hay más química más procesos y
advierten contra los riesgos que estos
cigarrillos puedan tener
o sea bueno yo los invito a ver un
reportaje uno de los tantos que he
producido esta semana no solo que habla
de el tema que refería al comienzo de la
emisión
leonardo que es el del invierno hemos
hemos tenido esta semana la llegada de
lo que podría considerarse la primera
tormenta invernal de esta temporada con
precipitaciones de 40 centímetros de
nieve en algunos casos que hizo que la
gente se asustará
y sobre todo que empezarán los
preparativos que se convierten en ritual
a lo largo de todo el invierno en todo
el país o en buena parte del país como
son por ejemplo poner las cubiertas de
inviernos los automóviles los abrigos
para resguardar a los autos de las
caídas de nieve veíamos nuestros abrigos
hace unas semanas atrás con el tema de
halloween la gente que iba a
guareciéndose con nuestros abrigos
calzado especial para no resbalarse en
el hielo o en la nieve previsiones que
hay que tomar para que el invierno sea
terrible terrible efectivamente y
después de todo está aquí y hay que
aprender a convivir con no nos queda más
tiempo no ya está organiza esa nueva
emisión de canadá las américas café que
suma a la larga lista de medios por el
cual ustedes pueden ver la aplicación
móvil que también transmite en vivo les
agradecemos una vez más haber estado con
todos nosotros
gracias natalie por haber estado
presente también hoy aquí en el estudio
te invitamos a que vuelvas cuando
quieras
[Música]